so tatiana that's got to be one of the
most
unique awards show related experiences
you've
ever been a part of how was that what
was that like
really it was i mean it was
bizarre it's bizarre but it's it's also
like uh
it's really impressive to me like how we
can still kind of make it feel
in some way you know it's it's just like
there's no other time that this is going
to be happening
so in this moment like to be that
resourceful and to be able to make it
like
you know leslie jones just kills it and
makes it entertaining and
yeah is that the way you're gonna ask
for people to say your name from now on
the way she said it just any any way
they want to
it's a it's a free-for-all my name's
always been a free-for-all
i respond to anything that starts with t
so as far as the nominations go were
there any that you were like
yes like i'm a huge fan of this show i'm
such a huge fan of this performer
yeah i mean i like binge watched um
ozark early in
uh quarantine and just was kind of like
addicted and fell into that
show like crazy um i also love
regina king in watchmen i just think
she's
extraordinary and yeah just brings so
much to a part that
um you know just such an incredible part
and just like continues to bring so much
interesting stuff to it
um and then also i'm like huge rupaul
drag race fan so
uh i'm i'm very happy about that one too
yeah and of course we just saw uh
eugene levy sandra oh um yes
does your heart get warmed a little bit
whenever you hear a canadian being
nominated
yeah i mean like for me you know
catherine o'hara was
was my hero before i even knew like
that she was canadian do you know what i
mean like when i was a kid
i would always look i looked up to her
so much and then to
you know get to meet her at the csas or
whatever backstage it was just
like she just she's so incredible and
has always been like
this icon for me in terms of incredible
acting and comedy
um so i'm you know outside of even being
canadian i'm
so excited about that but but yeah it is
kind of a cool thing to know
so many people who work on those shows
like all like so many of my friends work
on shit's creek
um you know and it's just yeah that's
super exciting
are you getting ready for when we um
hear your name announced for perry mason
next year
i'm getting ready for it yeah no i'm not
i'm uh not sure it will be
and if it is it will be butchered
probably name wise
oh my gosh it'll be amazing however they
say it'll be
titania yeah exactly i'll take any of it